bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va
comparer deux smartphones on va tester
d'un cocktail et wiko viewed pro que
vous avez ici et de l'autre côté de
samsung galaxy à six deux smartphones
sont dans le même budget aux alentours
des 300 euros et on va se demander
lequel est plus sympa lequel il faut
acheter les cahiers plus intéressante et
on y va
la famille samsung je voudrais un
smartphone milieu de gamme g ici le
samsung galaxy à 6 un excellent
smartphone je vous ai déjà fait une
vidéo de tester une vidéo d'un boxing le
produit est vraiment bien mais est-ce
qu'il est meilleur que le week au vieux
de pro parce que dans la famille wiko je
voudrais le vieux de pro qui est le
modèle le plus haut de gamme de chirico
donc là on est en compétition deux
produits le produit le plus haut de
gamme d'une marque d'une marque
française rico et le produit moyen de
gamme d'une très grande marque et
samsung c'est un petit peu un match
france corée du sud et on va voir lequel
est plus intéressant alors on compare
vraiment ces deux produits parce qu'en
terme de budget il se positionne tous
les deux aux alentours des 300 euros les
deux produits sont très récents et les
deux produits valent vraiment le coup
ils ont chacun leurs avantages et leurs
inconvénients mais tant qu'on va faire
un choix quand on veut acheter un
smartphone ou autour des 300 euros
lequel achetés entre le vieux de crau et
le samsung galaxy à 6 du point de vue
design les deux produits sont très bien
réussie vous n'avez pas du tout la même
fabrication la même conception le même
design sur le oui cause sur le vieux de
projets vraiment daube brillant avec ce
grand module photo ici de ce côté là au
centre le capteur d'empreintes digitales
tandis que sur le samsung galaxy à 6
vous avez un dos en est à côté un peu
plus mat le module photo au centre le
capteur d'empreintes digitales dessous
je préfère celui qu ce point de vue là
c'est que vous avez un accès direct
capteur d'empreintes digitales sans
risquer de mettre le doigt sur le module
photo tandis que sur le galaxy à 6 vous
êtes toujours un petit peu flirté avec
l'appareil photo
même si on en métal sur glace y sont
d'un côté un peu plus mat tandis que sur
le vieux de pros on n'écoutait que tu te
beaucoup plus brillant lors forcément
plus brillant plus de traces de doigts
mais c'est vrai quelques uns à côtés qui
est quand même un peu plus élégant plus
séduisants du côté des grecs 6 à 6 vous
avez un écran super amoled du côté du
oui qu'au vu de pro vous avez un écran
lcd super amoled et en tout cas beaucoup
plus sexy beaucoup plus joli que l'écran
lcd d'un point de vue design je suis
vraiment partagé j'aime bien lu qu'au vu
de pro j'aime bien ces petites encoches
trouve que c'est pas mal c'est léger ça
reste dans les critères qu'on actuelle
au niveau des encoches par contre
effectivement en bas on un bordeaux qui
est quand même assez proéminente
d'écouté serez coûter plus cher d'avoir
un écran qui viennent vraiment lécher le
bord comme on a sur l'iphone 10 je pense
que pour des coûts de production il
valait mieux mettre comme ça de leur
côté j'aime aussi beaucoup le design de
ce samsung galaxy à 6 vous avez ici une
bordure en haut une bordure en bas on a
des proportions qui sont vraiment garder
d'un côté comme de l'autre smartphone
qui pas du tout déséquilibré côté
puissance sur le samsung avec celle ci
si vous avez un exil au 7885 cadencé à
1,6 ghz 3 giga de ram 32 gigas le
stockage que pourrait monter jusqu'à 256
giga tandis que sur le vieux de pro vous
avez instinct dragonne 450 cadencé à 1,8
ghz
si la cad giga de ram 64 go de stockage
extensible jusqu'à 128 giga on a d'un
côté comme de l'autre une batterie de 3
min en terreur ils tournent tous les
deux sur un android oreo 8.0 du point de
vue photo vidéo les deux smartphones
sont plutôt bien et se tiennent plutôt
bien on a des résultats qui sont assez
intéressant celui que vous avez une
double caméra arrière 2 x 16 mégapixels
ouverture de f 1.75 tandis que sur le a6
vous avez un seul capteur arrière 16
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f
1.7 sens là si vous avez une caméra
avant de 16 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f
1.9 tandis que sur le week au vieux de
pro vous avez une caméra de 16
mégapixels est absolument aucune
information son ouverture point plutôt
intéressant sur le week au vu de procès
que vous avez une stabilisation logiciel
sur la caméra arrière lorsque vous allez
shooter ça vous corriger un petit peton
discussions à six
la stabilisation vous allez franchement
l'oublier vous allez film est d'un côté
comme de l'autre en 1080p vous allez
pouvoir faire des photos sympas des
souvenirs sympa sur le but de proposer
un capteur un peu plus classique et un
grand angle si vous voulez vous faire
plaisir après je passe sur que vous
allez utiliser parce que le rand lui va
pas être extraordinaire mais une fois de
plus sur un smartphone à 300 euros ça
fait la faire vous avez d'un côté loïc
au vieux de pro vous avez ici le samsung
le s6 voir un petit peu le rendu en
terme de vidéo voir ce qu'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît pas si c'est bien c'est
pas bien et si tu rencontres qu'elle est
la meilleure qualité entre le samsung et
amicaux vous avez une stabilisation a
souri qu'aux vous n'avez pas directement
sur le samsung de l'autre côté
[Musique]
et maintenant c'est les thèses du côté
les caméras de ses filles ici vous avez
le samsung est excessif ici c'est le
week au vu de pro je me sentais un peu
plus de 2 ou me voient carrément à la
même chose et un réglage incarnera une
seule caméra de toute façon ça va
changer grand chose
et quand même une vraie vraie vraie
différence pour coup entre les deux
caméras entre le salto je préfère
vraiment en dessous ou sur les caméras
elle fit de ce que je vais en tout cas
ici tout cas l'écran entre le samsung et
entre louis coquio de paul guth et alors
verdict quel est selon vous la caméra la
plus cool entre d'un côté le wiko view
deux pros qu'on a ici l'autre côté le
samsung galaxy à 6 ici bon là je vous ai
mis la petite voiture marque pour vous
puissiez vous repérer c'est assez rigolo
parce que c'est vraiment pas du tout du
tout du tout la même chose
on a une impression zoom sur la caméra
du ricoh view de pro une impression de
proximité
alors qu'avec la caméra du samsung
galaxy ace 6 mai un plus d'avoir un peu
plus de recul
c'est vraiment rigolo parce que le rendu
n'est pas du tout le même mais dans les
deux cas c'est assez intéressant tout
cas c'est vraiment intéressant parce que
là pour le coup on a une vraie
différence totale qu'on dit moi pour
vous laquelle vous préférez en
commentaires entre l'antre la caméra de
celle fille du samsung galaxy à 6 et du
oui convenu de promouvoir en termes de
photos et vidéos les deux smartphones
ont quand même chacun leurs
particularités
j'ai vraiment vu une différence lors du
tournage hors de la prise de photo
d'un côté et de l'autre mais
effectivement je le verrai réellement au
montage et à ce moment là c'est vous qui
allez me le dit mon commentaire lequel
vous préférez lequel vous trouvez le
plus intéressant pour la photo et pour
la vidéo
mark et moi tout ça directement en bas
en commentaire dans les deux cas vous
avez du bluetooth 4.2 du nfc la
possibilité d'avoir une double carte sim
une extension de capacité de stockage
avec une carte micro sd tous les deux un
port jack tous les deux produits sont
vraiment bien au final verdict quel est
le meilleur smartphone entre d'un côté
le week au vu de pro et de côté le
samsung galaxy à 6 alors c'est compliqué
à lire ce soit compliqué parce que les
deux produits sont intrinsèquement
vraiment bien vraiment intéressant ils
ont chacun leur adn ils sont quand même
suffisamment marqué l'un comme l'autre
pour avoir de vraies différences
notables et différence leur donne des
points positifs mais leur confère aussi
les points négatifs goûter du vieux de
ce qui me plaît c'est ce daube riant
c'est ce double module photo le capteur
d'empreinte digitale au centre je trouve
pas mal le grand écran de 6 pouces des
petites encoches me plaisent bien je
trouve que l' os fonctionne bien je
trouve que l'appareil kc fonctionnel je
trouve vraiment intéressant maintenant
du côté du samsung galaxy à 6 ce qui
plaît beaucoup c'est la qualité de
l'écran je préfère l'écran super amoled
du à 6 par rapport à l'écran du week au
vieux de pro je trouve que le design est
un peu plus classique néanmoins très
bien structuré avec la même grandeur de
bas en haut et en bas le dow est pas fou
il surprend pas le design n'est pas
complètement dingue c'est un design qui
est efficace c'est un design qui a déjà
été vu c'est un design qu'on a vu qu'on
verra probablement il invente rien il
cassera quelques fois comme un canard
mais il est efficace d'un point de vue
design
je préfère quand même le view de projet
prouve qu'il ya un vrai travail des
tarifs haricots et un vrai bel effort
maintenant côté appareil photo/vidéo
j'ai quand même une vraie préférence sur
samsung samsung fait toujours des très
bons appareils
les rendus sont claires nettes efficace
l'autofocus fonctionne bien et on n'est
jamais déçu sur le lieu de projet trouve
qu'il ya aussi de très très beaux
efforts qui ont été faits par rico pour
vraiment avoir un produit de bonne
qualité pour avoir un appareil très
complet pour avoir de la vidéo et de la
photo de bonne qualité néanmoins je
donne le point de ce point de vue là
pour la photo vidéo ou samsung galaxy à
6 côté performances je donnerai aussi un
point supplémentaire directement aux
assisses avec son exil aux 7885 pour moi
dans la mesure où on doit faire un choix
entre le samsung galaxy à six et de
l'autre côté le week au vu de pro
écoutez j'ai quand même un penchant pour
ce samsung galaxy s histoire que
vraiment lu qu'au vu de pro est un super
produit mais je trouve que samsung même
si elle y ait un peu plus classique est
vraiment linéaire en termes de qualité
linéaire au niveau de l'écran linéaire
au niveau du design linéaire au niveau
de l'appareil photo avant comme arrière
ce que je veux dire par linéaires c'est
que le produit est vraiment complet est
vraiment cohérent dans l'ensemble il n'y
a pas un produit qui est vraiment
beaucoup plus fort et le reste qui est
assez moyen tout est vraiment cohérent
et pour un prix aux alentours de 300
euros il est vraiment complètement
cohérent dans l'ensemble je trouve que
le vus de pro est vraiment un produit
qui est très jolie et très bien réussi
mais il a quand même une certaine
disparité il ya un écart l'écran et bien
je trouve que du côté photo du côté
vidéo c'est un petit peu moins ça c'est
bien forcèrent des souvenirs c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est vraiment
positif je trouve que wilko va dans le
bon sens mikko va vraiment cherché à
avoir les produits de
toujours meilleure qualité mais il faut
encore monter un petit peu je pense en
qualité tant au niveau des caméras après
l'écran lcd ça fonctionne et pour lui
d'avoir un écran oled là dessus il fait
le job
on va pas se mentir c'est très bien pour
300 euros il est vraiment très très bien
sûr que c'est un très joli produits
sains produits qui très bien fini si
vous aimez design du likoud pro vous
pourriez faire mais vous serez pas déçus
et si vous voulez un appareil qui est
vraiment plutôt bon sur tous les points
le samsung galaxy sii voilà pour ce
comparatif dites moi ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
moi est ce que vous aimez les produits
de wipro est ce que vous aimez les
produits samsung entre les deux produits
vers lequel va votre préférence vous
marquez tout sans commentaire je suis à
votre écoute pour toutes vos questions
suggestions avis demande de comparatifs
et tout ça et je le ferai dans la mesure
du possible d'ici là soyez ça je vous
embrasse
abonnez vous mettez moi des jeunes
pousses et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]